we will stay here as long as it takes to
get an agreement
and we urge mr meadows to sit down and
continue to work with us
um to do it as long as it takes by
friday if we haven't made significant
progress
and we're just too far apart the
president is prepared to take an
executive action
no deal yet on the next chronovirus
relief bill democrats and republicans
still negotiating on capitol hill white
house chief of staff mark meadows says
if an agreement is not reached by
tomorrow it is doubtful
there will be any deal at all chad
pergram's live on capitol hill so chad
what are you seeing
any signs of progress this morning not
really sandra i mean they are hundreds
of billions if not trillions apart here
that's the problem these negotiations
have gone on for days
the only place a movement is on
unemployment insurance they're a little
bit closer there
but just the length of these talks
that's what's frustrating mark meadows
i can just tell you that uh there are no
top-line numbers that have been agreed
to
the that we continue to be you know
trillions of dollars apart
in terms of of what uh
democrats and republicans hopefully will
ultimately compromise on
this is a thicket of negotiations with
dozens of thorny issues
they are nowhere close on food
assistance not close on school aid
all they've accomplished in these talks
is narrowed the list of issues where
they think there can be an agreement
house speaker nancy pelosi called this a
quote an unusual negotiation
i feel optimistic that there is a light
at the end of the tunnel
but how long that tunnel is remains to
be seen
this is where if there's no deal they
could take executive action
over the weekend or maybe next week
that's where the president has talked
maybe sandra
about a moratorium on evictions and also
suspending the collection of payroll
taxes sandra chad why do they think that
they can get a deal done now after
two weeks of negotiations
well they don't that's what's so
interesting about this and this was
summed up by meadows yesterday afternoon
listen this is not a fine wine it
doesn't improve with time
the senate hasn't tried to advance an
interim plan on unemployment insurance
despite suggestions
that that would happen this week and fox
is told that any measure there may only
command
about 40 gop votes now if there's not an
agreement
fox is told that the administration
could try to use some
unused coronavirus money from old bills
back in march
also money from the disaster relief fund
if they can't get an agreement
sandra we'll see where all this goes
chad pergram great to see you thank you